allez maintenant les chéris il est 20
heures pile vous avez deux minutes pour
me poser toutes les questions que vous
dressez
on y va c'est parti qui veut commencer
vous avez deux minutes là vous n'avez
plus maintenant qu'une minute 52
géraldine maillet il ya un livre qui se
prépare est ce que vous avez le trac le
trac de livres ban devait tracer juge
après oui je sais mais doit s'assurer un
10e au top voilà du lancement moi j'en
en ratant le plus grand bien est-ce que
vous appréhendez est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui vous excite vous êtes
dans quel état d'esprit aucun n'a
vraiment le mieux d'être content vous
attend la suisse est très content parce
que saint pierre on est fiers parce que
c'est chez fayard c'est une grande mer
une édition avec christophe barbier
isabelle ça ben thanh voilà que j'ai
adoré mais j'ai juste envie j'ai juste
hâte que les téléspectateurs et les
ligneurs on le verrait le découvre pas
ce que je pense qu'ils ont été étonnés
et jeudi énormément de choses dedans je
me confie comme vraiment je me suis
rarement confié sur pas mal de choses
oui j'ai le garder personnellement je
vous trouve plus en forme plus drôle que
jamais est ce que est ce que c'est la
meilleure saison que tpm paix que vous
présentez en ce moment de votre point ça
doit être oui avec la avec les deux
premières oui je pense voilà je sais
vraiment les sens je le dis oui ccc
voilà je la mets dans le top 3 et pour
l'un est vraiment c'est incroyable ce
qui se passe cette année merci à vous
d'être aussi nombreux et c'est vrai
qu'on se régale et vous le sentez
benjamin qu'est ce qui pourrait vous
faire quitter l'antenne qu'est ce qui
pourrait me faire quitter l'antenne
titre la place un choix si on veut plus
de moi l'antenne voilà et si les
médiateurs sont plus assis là à
l'imaginer le psg vous demande à la
direction
du club
du paris
saint-germain du paris saint germain ont
été évoqués cyril
la vérité le président du paris
volley réfléchi
et j'aimais énormément président nasser
qui fait un travail exceptionnel mais
voilà en dessous de lui ne serait pas
mal voilà évoqué cela alors oui valérie
vous allez faire bientôt une émission
politique
une nouvelle émission est ce que ça a
été difficile de convaincre la direction
et puis les hommes à l'homme politique
hors jeu vous dire les hommes et femmes
politiques pas du tout parce qu'ils ont
tous dit oui pour l'instant on n'a eu
que des réponses positives pratiquement
et la direction jours on a la chance ici
d'avoir une direction qui nous fait
confiance à 100% vraiment c'est
incroyable voilà et mon écoute voilà on
te suit il m'aide à voile à faire cette
émission mais il n'y a aucune pression
vraiment ces voix là on te suit on y
croit
[Musique]
généralement il faut en général en deux
mois pour que les audiences s'installe
en début de saison là elles se sont
installées immédiatement comment vouloir
piquer je vous expliquer parce que
d'habitude je change tout pendant les
tic serait ça comme je m'emmerde pendant
l'été cet été je me suis pas embêtés
voilà j'ai passé un bel été et ben
béchir y j'ai pas eu le temps de penser
au travail et donc je n'ai rien changé
et donc l'émission il retrouvé comme ils
n'ont laissé à la rentrée donc voila
voila en fait l'application elle est
juste là oui oui qu'est-ce qui vous a
donné envie de faire ce métier l'argent
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui c'est votre anniversaire
alors pour cette nouvelle année qui
s'offre à vous qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter ou qu'est ce que vous vous
soyez losail vous franchement d'autant
rigoler que c'est tel que ce qu'on a
fait depuis le début d'année là je vis
on vit une année exceptionnelle vraiment
que voilà qu'on continue à s'éclater
avec vous tous les soirs si c'est mon
kiff abso du week end
merci
quelles sont vos relations actuelles
avec arthur a mais aucune relation il
m'a fait un procès voilà pour tout vous
dire un procès sur le fond bull vraiment
qui ne tient pas debout voilà parce
qu'il dit qu'on dénigre ses émissions
alors qu'il faisait c'est comme si
france je le faisais un procès parce que
je dénigre essayer c'est qu'on décolle
n'y a aucun projet a aucun problème
enfin il ya aucune relation avec arthur
et il y en aura je pencherais
étrangement chacun fait sa vie et je
souhaite moi ça s'agace une relation qua
non ma nation
moi je fais jamais de procès moi je ne
fais jamais de procès parce que c'est
pas du tout mon truc moi je préfère
aller voir le mec directement